this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] uncle
joey here it's monday the 7th of
february the joint is brought to you by
addict listen
for 10 years now i've been messing
around with on it and they only keep
getting better and better and better i
just want to tell you everything's in
stock including
that black label alpha brain tremendous
if you haven't done it i'm waiting for
my next bottle so i get my next cycle
started but go to honor.com and look at
all the great supplements that they have
and the protein powders the mexican
chocolate listen they're tremendous
i'll tell you i'm a little upset because
they're out of
the protein bites but hey you can't
always get what you want you get what
you need go to honor.com right now look
at all the great supplements
get that alpha brain to get your year
[__] started pressing code joey or
joint or church
and get 10 percent off delivered right
to your house that's honest.com
code
church joey or joint
the joint is also brought to you by blue
chew listen you're seven days away from
valentine's day general gentlemen you
got to give your girl what she wants a
big fat arrow in her heart-shaped box
let blue shoe be your personal cupid you
sho you're showing up with a [__]
cape and a big blue dick
that's what blue chew does for you all
jokes aside blue chew is tremendous
listen i'm not saying that you suffer
from erectile dysfunction but you always
want to show up with all your barrels
filled you understand me blue chew is
tremendous it works fast
and it tastes good you drink it you eat
it
ship it down with water it tastes like
those blue violets when you were a kid
you could take it any time day or night
and it's simple sign up at bluetooth.com
and talk to one of the licensed medical
providers once you're approved you
receive your prescription within days
the best part it's all online nobody
knows nothing no doctor's office no
pharmacy no judgment it ships right to
your door to discreet package even the
mailman don't know what's going on
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
right then and there you're doing
something good you're keeping it in the
american way nothing but heart balls and
a big blue dick
on valentine's day so if you could
benefit from extra confidence when it's
time to sling dick with three hands blue
chew can help you and it's easy like i
told you
no drama and they got a special deal for
the joint listeners you could try blue
chew for free
when you use promo code joey at checkout
just pay five dollars for shipping it's
that easy that's bluetooth.com promo
code joey to receive your first month
for free i'm gonna save you money and
your dick is gonna love me you
understand me it's gonna be like that
[__] thing on hulu your dick's gonna
talk to you tell uncle joey i send them
my love to visit bluechew.com for more
details and important safety information
i want to thank bluechu for sponsoring
the joint i also want to thank and it's
their biggest week of the year so if i
was you i download the app right now i'm
talking about the draftking sportsbook
app and i'm talking about this sunday
super bowl 50 [__] six and
we're the official sports betting
partner of super bowl and the nfl has a
tremendous offer for new customers get
56-1 odds on either team whether the la
rams
or the cincinnati bengals if your bench
is five dollars that's it guys listen i
know i'm not saying you you bet all the
time but this is the week come on
stick a [__] pipe up your ass it's
time to get down if your team wins what
do you got to lose five dollars
or more and you get 280 and free bets
now you don't want to bet the super bowl
listen i got a whole weekend for you we
got mma this weekend we got tons of ways
to bet saturday's big ufc 270
one card in h town drove down on who win
each fight and how the fight will finish
and so much more fists are gonna fly so
listen it starts saturday at the ufc and
the party continues
sunday with the super bowl we got prop
bets we got everything download the
draftkings sportsbook now and use promo
code joey if you want to go with the
draftkings fantasy app they listen the
top prize is a million dollars so you do
what you got to do i'm both of them
promo code joey at draftkings sportsbook
app the official sports betting partner
of super bowl 56 now you gotta be 21
older minimum age and location
requirements vary by jurisdiction see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for full list of requirements
and state specific responsible gaming
resources void we're prohibited now you
got a gambling problem called 1-800
gambling if you're in tennessee call
1-800-889-9789
if you're in connecticut 888 7897
[Music]
if you're in new york
87 7 8
hope
new york but if you're straight let's
get the party started and it starts
really friday night with the nba
saturday mma ufc and sunday the super
bowl
code joey let's get this party
[__] started jack it's monday
morning
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's your uncle joey bringing your joy
on a monday morning the 7th of february
what's your joy joy what are you
bringing me a box of [__] what are you
bringing me a box 100 bills
nah
a different [__] outlook on things
i'm happy it's a beautiful day to be
alive it's february
in jersey that means you could wake up
and it could be [__] 60 degrees
or 10 below and guess what let's go with
the [__] ladder 10 below there's no
60s in february on the east coast it's
[__] cold jack
went over the pa this weekend it's even
[__] colder there it was like 16
degrees
but it was a great time and that's all
that [__] matters i'm dipped up my
goo
i'm looking good i'm ready to go
smoking weed again that's what the
problem with the [__] world is
right now
people gave up on rifa
it's a religion get back to it you know
what i was a little umbots for a [__]
couple months there you know i thought i
was done with reef i really [__]
thought so it wasn't doing anything to
me
it was just giving me more anxiety than
what i had then the anxiety [__] uh
went away and i got stuck with me
johnny does and i'm like what am i going
to do all day think about what i'm no
[__] buddha i'm not yeah johnny
what do you want me to think about it
you want me you think like my mind is
deep so i like said [__] it
and uh now i smoke before i head to the
gym 11 o'clock through the treadmill you
know
just a [__] brand there's a there's
two dudes at the gym who won't shut the
[__] up
nice people
they're a couple she don't say [__] she
just walks around she's lucky to be
alive but the husband is like 38
sweetheart of a guy sweetheart of a
[__] guy
but he won't shut the [__] up during
workouts show you what kind of music do
you like joey what do you eat at night
shut the fabric stop stop so the other
day i had to go up to america you
haven't shut the [__] up once you're
messing with me right joey
he's uh he's tremendous so it's his
birthday i want to shout him out maybe
give him an edible like a 10 milligram
to put him where he [__] belongs but
my point was that when i go down there
you know i've been going to the same gym
since i moved here
for like a year it would get to me
and recently
it doesn't bother me at all you know why
we [__] that's why i go in there [__]
blasted for those freeze pipe bong hits
for breakfast
you go in there reeking of reefer
looking like grandpa from the monsters
smoke coming out from every [__]
orifice
and you know what i don't even hear him
anymore
when i walk i put the [__] earbuds on
and listen to a little deaf leopard
whatever the [__] is cooking on the
phone that day
and i take the buds off and i lift and i
hear him like every once in a while it's
like somebody's drowning you know when
you walk on the beach
say you know that type of [__] that's
what you hear from time that's it i
don't it doesn't even bother me one of
the trainers is like doesn't bother you
anymore i'm not cause i'm smoking dope
in the morning he goes smoking dope
shuts out the noise i go smoking dope
shuts out everything you know what i'm
saying anyway
i wanted to talk to you guys about
something i started the story on patreon
the other day you know
i do a little patreon 20-minute podcast
twice a week and it's [__] perfect
for me because
i could just dump you know dump and it's
always great when you have a podcast
that you could just dump on because
you don't know what's going to come out
during the dump it's like a journal only
vocal you know what i'm saying you don't
and that's how i treat that podcast i
love doing a 20 minute [__] podcast
you stare at nothing
there's no camera you know people always
go you should have a camera [__] no
this is a little better sometimes a
little bit more private
but for some reason uh
i was thinking of this dude mr blue
mr blue was my prison counselor
and you know that
every week i think of mr bloom one way
or another
because he gave me like that push he
gave me like that like he gave me
something to work for
i've had you know 200 people that
stepped up for me
and i probably let 60 of them down so
i'm up about 40.
so i'm all right but
you know for a long time i was letting
people down when they would step up for
me and then
you know you grow the [__] up and
when somebody steps up for you you
[__] feeling your [__] bones and
you go you know what
i gotta [__] pay my debt back and
it's not money it's just some flaw in
your character that you want to adjust
you know
so with me it was just my attitude you
know i thought i was bad [__] when i
went to prison and mr blue let me know
there was [__] hope when there's hope
everything's great you know so
we were talking about my roofing career
how i got into [__] roofing
and a lot of people know about my
roofing days the funny thing was i did a
thousand jobs you know and i i wasn't
happy with any of them
and all of a sudden somewhere comedy was
in my backbone like it was like
maybe i'll look at the comedy i'm not
sure you know what i'm saying like you
never [__] commit to it
but i got a roofing gig and it was the
first job that
i saw a future in
but guess what it was too late i had to
give comedy a [__] try now i had
waited you know 28 [__] years
and just because i had the job i
kind of liked
what you always get with me it was
always an advantage to do something that
i kind of liked you know when i look at
my
job resume you know i was trying to see
what i was eligible doing what i could
do with my life
i put like this pseudo thing of my
experience everything i did was like a
year
anything past the year that i did i
really liked
and there was a future in it but i
didn't know
you know when it came to roofing i
[__] loved everything about it i
loved
you know
sawing the [__] rubes and taking the
[__] old roof off and
putting the [__] insulation down and
then putting the [__] rubber down
then putting the rocks on it was called
ballasted ropes that's that's all i ever
did for about 18 [__] months
was ballasted ruth maybe like
16 months i did ballast to roost it
wasn't something
i had done sheet rock i had done i had
painted
i had done brick work i had done
carpentry you know
uncle joey did it all i built walls with
[__] railroad ties
we had to drill the [__] thing
through i think i lasted eight hours on
that job not even i think i lasted until
my lunch time
i [__]
dug up
the dirt and put pot pipe in with holes
in it i forget what it's called
insulated pipe or some [__] i did it all
i did it all there's some [__] i really
enjoyed
there's some stuff you could smoke a
joint and the day disappears like being
a brick mason oh my god we were getting
there [__] 6 30 in the morning get
blasted
and you know the sun's out you're laying
[__] break you're stalking brick for
the masons you're [__]
making water you know
16 scoops of sand it's sunny out you got
[__] uh sand all over you
suntan lotion [__] those are the days
but then one day you're doing you're
like i'm doing all this for nine dollars
an hour i could sell on eight ball make
[__] 200. i'm out here sweating like
[__] alibaba in the 40 thieves get
the [__] out of here
you know that's what usually happened to
me i had to [__] deal a mentality
but
i uh
i got out of [__]
prison
and i went to work for myself at first
for a while for about six months just to
get you know i was i wasn't gonna go i
wasn't gonna come out of [__] the
camp
and then go into the halfway house and
then get a job inside there was no way
that was gonna work i had just been
inside
for 14 [__] months i wanted something
that i drove around and
when i got to the halfway house they
told me i couldn't [__] drive [__]
that you know my bicycle was done i had
sold the bike i'm not riding a [__]
bike no i'm a goddamn adult so
i got myself a little gig a detailing my
own little cars i had a little couple
used car dealerships they wouldn't pay
me dick i was breaking even
but i was selling some [__] powder i
did whatever i had to keep the [__]
lights on at the halfway house
and then uh i smartened up a little bit
and
i went to work at boulder toyota and
again
i had [__] around the car business for
years i got locked up
while i was selling cars so i had a bad
taste in my mouth i went to boulder
toyota was the [__] best car salesman
job i had i was making from 3 500 to 5
000 a month i had great hours great
[__] mentors that's
where the dude jim handy put the bug in
my ear about doing stand-up you know and
i was like what the [__] he talking
about and
you know he told his son he was thinking
of quitting and taking me on the road
but i'm like what's this guy talking
about [__] stand-up comedy this guy
has to go get a cocktail or something
he'd always talk to me are you writing
any jokes yet no i'm not writing no
jokes go away what i'm saying like now i
thank him and i go jesus thanks for
staying on me
so i worked for him for about four
months you know i was on probation they
would come check me out over there it
was kind of [__] embarrassing the
dude that i was always give the pistol
with the [__] alka-seltzer and [__]
that dude would come hop me down and
look at my eyes and
so kind of got embarrassing and you know
what
my my father-in-law at the time
was a good dude talking about somebody
who stepped up for me he
you know i mean he did the ultimate
stand up for me
put the bail up he [__]
wrote letters he talked to the judges he
went to the hearing
for probation i mean my father-in-law
was a [__] great dude and when he
opened up like that
it brought something out of me so
i could tell he wasn't happy that i was
back selling cars he felt i was going to
get into the same rut
little did he know i was already
snorting and stuff like that but i was a
little bit more professional about it i
was keeping it under as professional as
you could be when you snort coke i mean
that's the dumbest thing in the world
but you know
so uh
he kind of talked me he's like hi
i'm worried that you're gonna get back
in the same rut and i'm like nah i like
it these guys are all family guys there
was no boozers
there was a great dealership you know i
learned something really important at
that dealership though
it was about 89
[Music]
and i remember i was really getting into
salesmanship you know kind of stuff and
i bought a book
telemarketing in the 80s
and when i went to boulder toyota
they had everything down it was owned by
the utah jazz the owner of the utah jazz
and the people he had an upper
management there were all [__]
mormons not i got nothing against them
they were nice people but they were by
the book and you understood why they
were [__] gazillionaires because they
did everything and they spent money
i learned big when i worked over there
because they spent money on themselves
that toyota dealership every month sent
you somewhere
anthony robbins whatever his [__]
name is
sales seminars they sent you they spent
a lot of money but where they spent the
most money was training in
house they didn't want to hire people
from the outside
and one of the things they really
focused on was one of my favorites the
[__] phone
you know i was okay on the phones till i
went to work there when i went to work
there i became a [__] professional
and it's weird how from every job i took
a little something so
there were two phones there you know
when you work at a car dealership
they'll just go sales call on line one
wherever the [__] you are you fly to the
phone line one how you doing this is
joey how can i help you i'm looking for
an 82 subaru all right i got one come on
now you you just get this [__]
conversation going yeah they give you a
little training when you start they tell
you never to reveal the price
or the mileage you want people to
[__] come in
you know what when you got somebody on
the phone that's easier said than done
because they rattle you to death until
they get what they want then they ask
you for the best price which you're not
supposed to give out the best price you
got to go around the [__] uh ben so
what these [__] did was they
got two phones
one on the right side of the showroom on
the left side of the show like 50 yards
away from each other
both phones belong to a sales service
the salesman came in every tuesday
he sat on the sales meeting from the
toyota people he sat on the sales
meeting from the management staff
and then he would have his own meeting
with percentages and [__] like that of
how many calls you took he would listen
they also had two tape recorders and
each phone on each side
so as soon as you pressed how you doing
this is joey
the tape recorder would go off and tape
you thank god it wasn't sophisticated
system it was the old school ones that
were used in bookmaking offices in the
70s it was a cassette player with a wire
and the wires connected to the uh
the [__] handle the phone
for some people that are too young
you're like joey what phone had chords i
know i'm confusing you [__] i'm
bringing you back into the like jerry
what the [__] was electricity then yeah
everything was solid so
we had the two phones so what the girl
would say was
sales call
and you had to go to your phone pick it
up and go marry mary i got it and she go
what where do you want it phone one or
phone two
phone one was on the left side phone two
was on the right side i was closer to
phone one
i started going on there and i would
just do what i do
but there was really a pitch
i would just do what i do
and guess what it wasn't working let's
be honest you know
so the guy would bring me up there on
tuesday and go listen you received four
[__] sales call on wednesday what'd
you do with them did you sell a car you
didn't even do the paperwork on it and
i'm like yeah i sold the card i got him
in from the phone you know but he's like
joey
you're bullshitting me if you don't do
this correctly i'm gonna pull you off
the phones
guys you know i was a [__] jackal
i came back with a plan
not to mention they were selling 20 cars
a [__] month off that phone
because it's boulder people call around
they're intelligent they don't have time
to shop they're smoking a pipe
they got their [__] birken socks on
so
i did something that was genius criminal
but genius i went over the phone number
two and i disconnected the [__] tape
recorder
no no no no no no
phone number two which is farthest from
me i just disconnected the phone
so i would watch those salesmen run over
and go i gotta marry and then she would
go they would go line two and they'd run
over the line too and they'd pick up the
phone and i'd go to line one and have it
how you doing this is joey and they'd be
over there i can't get it what the [__]
is going on and i'm on the phone over
there something like a [__] come
on down yeah it's joey whatever and they
started they every tuesday again joey
why are you getting all the [__]
calls you know hey listen i don't know
the [__] phone's broken then the guy
figured out i was disconnected the phone
so now i did one better he would go
upstairs he would stay and listen as
soon as he left i disconnected the
[__] phone over there
and i disconnected the tape recorder on
mine
so i had the phone disconnected in two
and the tape recorder disconnected in
one so it was a [__] smorgasbord
i was doing whatever the [__] i want i
was taking those calls
telling them to suck my dick we weren't
taping them nobody had knowledge that
they
when they come in the receptionist has
knowledge of it but nobody else the guy
was coming on tuesday jesus christ
somebody just clicked the phone again
and they disconnected the [__] tape
recorder on the other phone this went on
for about two [__] months
the guy knew it was me i mean he you
know after a while i was just doing it
at the torch room that was it because he
come back and he was one of those white
guys he was i'm flabbergasted you know
one of those dudes and [__] so
nice dude i still remember what he
looked like i forget his name
and he cut me a [__] deal
he goes i'm gonna take you off the
phones for a week until we get this [__]
organized
but when we come back
i'm not going to put you back on the
phone
till you sell three phone cards from me
from script the script was genius
whoever wrote the script was genius i
just didn't have the balls to say it as
a [__] dude i was like that's pushy
but no they didn't give you the price of
the car they didn't give you the mileage
didn't even give you the color of the
[__] car
if you stuck to that [__] thing and
had the objections
so if you said i can't come in today my
cat got hit by a car we had [__]
everything drilled for you a b c d and
then take it right back to a and grind
them grind them grind them
guys
do you know i did that for about three
weeks and i was the top phone salesman
that [__] for two months in a
row he cut me a deal every time you win
i'll take it to the best restaurant
around to [__] eat on tuesdays for
lunch i won that award like three
[__] months running when you put a
steak dinner lobster tail in front of
uncle joey in sales
[__] the dude loved me even after i left
the dude kept in touch with me to see if
i wanted to go work for the company as
one of the traveling salesmen like
helping other dealerships i'm like
come on guy i'm a [__] criminal i'm
on blow i can't work out for you
it hurt me to leave boulder toyota
but i had to make my father more happy
and i did
[Music]
and at that age you know what
listen the real me would have said [__]
you i'm doing what i want but doing what
i want wasn't getting me anywhere so
i listened to them i had connections at
this place to puddle car wash
it was great [__] tremendous money
for a kid my age with no degree great
money i wish them all the luck in the
world i started there drying off cars
i quit correctly i kept in touch with
them i brought customers in there i
would go in there all the time then one
day they asked me do you want to come
work i was like what as a host that's
the best job there and i split it with
somebody else it was a seven day a week
job
but i would split it like one week i'd
work four days on work i'd worked three
days didn't matter i was pulling down
like two grand the [__] week in that
[__] a thousand of it was cash
it was [__] tremendous tips
towels i got to meet the sheriff's
department i got to meet the da's i got
to meet the undercover cops
it was just a [__] great job and i
was out there all day
some days you froze some days it was too
hot but i didn't give a [__] i got to
meet
the sports betting guys stu finer and
all those guys oh everything happened to
that [__] car wash the problem with
me
and that car wash was i wasn't living
right
and eventually it was gonna come back to
bite me in the ass and if i [__] up at
that car wash
the whole town would know
they had already given me his chance
when i got out of prison
with this [__] job and now i'm gonna
[__] [__] it up
so i was up with my in-laws one sunday
for dinner with my wife and the baby and
we're talking [__]
and my brother and i go what are you
guys doing in boulder because they were
in jersey
doing roofs with their other
brother-in-law they started a roofing
company
they go no we're gonna move back here
and and get the company going here we
got a big job
we got a two-year job
and uh
we're just building the crew and all
this [__]
and we were just talking you know the
way we're bullshitting right now
and uh my father-in-law at the time goes
joey
maybe you should go on the roof one day
a week with them you have a really
flexible job and i was like
yeah yeah i'll go up there [__] you
those guys work my brother-in-law
brother-in-law's [__] worked
when i saw him at the end of the day
those guys were [__]
just
black and dark from the sun and [__]
drunk they drank on the roofs i was like
i'm not going on a roof and drinking
[__] beers i thought who the [__] i
am
but you know what my wife said to me you
should go up there with them they're the
best roofers they were tremendous they
had
they had all gone to college had a
college education but they started
roofing when they were like 12 at this
company called black roofing in boulder
and by the time they were [__] out of
college they were [__] master roofers
so they opened up their own company and
you know ten years later i hooked up
with them you know in nineteen
and i would go out there two days a week
one day a week two days a week
and then when i go [__] i need
something to fall back on at the puddle
you know i was going to quit the puddle
like i need something i don't know how
much they're going to pay me they were
paying me okay on the daily as me just
showing up and helping them [__]
eight hours of giving me great money i
forget what the [__] it was
they said to me we'll give you a
full-time job if you want to give your
company truck
i was like [__] let's do it you know and
in my mind i'm like [__] it i got a
country comfy job no
in my mind where i came from when your
family gives you a job
you got to work hard and everybody else
on that [__] team
period
i never wanted to be where your
brother-in-law gets to come in at 10
o'clock in the morning no i wasn't
taking that job
to be a shitty person i was taking that
job i just got out of prison
you know and this is about me this
wasn't part of it was my father-in-law
but part of it was really me and i went
to that [__] job
and i loved it and after about a month
they go listen do you have any friends
you you want to hire and i'm like [__]
yeah i had this friend mike roebuck that
i knew from 83
in snowmass village he was living in
boulder now i got him a job like making
six 700 a week i would pick him up in
the mornings we'd smoke dope
[__] get to the rules put the ladder
up carry [__] up there was a guy that
was there because we needed help
he had a friend called jim a jimmy the
guy must have been 60
and he was a great old man i remember
one day i took a [__] in a baggie and
gave it to him told him it was a brownie
and he's like ah it smells weird you
know the whole f i mean we used to have
a blast on that
there was a six-man crew
including no man jim and if you're a
roofer you know what i'm talking about
we were tearing down
40 squares a day
lifting it was two roofs that were
existing we were tearing off two
existing 19 [__] 10 roofs
and then putting sheet uh insulation
like inch installation three-quarter
insulation i thought it was 30 years ago
don't [__] give me a math test now
it was a long time ago we put the
insulation then we'd roll the rubber out
all six of us will push the rubber
across the roof
and then
2 30 every day a [__] truck would
back up
with a bunch of [__] stone
and it would back it into a
a belt that would take it to four three
stories up and we'd be up there with a
[__] wheelbarrow one after the other
running it out dumping it running it out
dumping it old man jim would be out
there [__] raking the rocks it was
tremendous we we checked out every day
at 3 30. we got there at seven and i
[__] loved it i [__]
loved that i was outside he was smoking
dope on the roof we were smoking dope
out of a can
when it got too hot or too windy my
brother-in-law built the [__] reefer
shack a [__] reefer shack that's how
[__] much of a stoner my i had two
brother-in-laws my one brother-in-law
both of them were dynamite
my one brother-in-law was just a drinker
he didn't touch nothing just
booze and he stayed out all night with
just booze they called him the prowler
and my other brother-in-law was the [__]
genius stoner
this guy only bought weed and a quarter
pound
he didn't buy a quarter ounce
he didn't buy an eight
he didn't buy an ounce
when this guy went to cop he would buy a
quarter pound
and he drove around his truck with a
bomb a three foot bong and a quarter
pound behind each [__] seat because
he didn't want to smoke the same weed
every day he's the one that taught me he
don't smoke the same [__] weed every
day
thought this guy we would get bliss on
that job it was just perfect
we worked on it for about a year
and i liked my job i had [__] uh
i liked it i don't know how old i was 30
31 i was in the best shape of my [__]
life
i think my buddy
mike ronnie has some pictures you'll die
if i post these i look like [__]
tarzan
i'm dark like felipe esparza i remember
they came out to visit me we did
something
and i had a pink shirt on and i'm darker
than the paint like it's [__] i'm
like jesus christ how dark was i
when i worked on that roof because
colorado has as much sun as hawaii for
you [__] who don't know
now you know yeah i know joey global
warming i know i know but they do they
really [__] do
so you get dark working like that
so
i'm on the roof one day and we're
talking [__] during one of the breaks
the breaks were tremendous
the first we get that 6 30 we'd be on
the roof by seven
and then at 10 we'd go get green chili
burrito green chili
with two eggs sunny side up baked potato
potatoes and bacon
i'd get the [__] green chili and just
pour it on the [__] eggs oh come on i
cooked the [__] yolk i had wheat
toast and i had [__] what wheat toast
i didn't even know a wheat toast was
that wonder bread white and [__]
tortillas and i dip it into the green
chili i was a [__] savage
that was our first lunch and then we had
lunch again at 12 and then like at two
before the truck came with the stone we
took like a 15 minute that's when we
[__] burn up
to death in there but one day we were
just talking
and we were talk they were talking about
hiring a salesman
that this job was coming to an end in
about six months
it takes six to eight months to bid new
commercial work this was subcontract
so what that meant was black roofing was
giving my in-laws work
they were keeping the heavy-duty profit
we were getting a good profit but we
were also
you know working our butts off and they
were taking the chunk of the [__] doe
so i went to them i'm like listen i'm no
[__] uh
roofer or nothing but i know profit and
this
subcontract work is great i know you
guys are in it i know you guys picked
this up to get you through the door but
now we gotta
you know [__] do something they're
like well if you want to learn how to do
i mean they just said it to me
like they thought i was gonna go yeah
that's not what i'm gonna do
i'm just gonna move the [__] on and stay
a labor
i told them i said listen i'm thinking
that maybe i'll start learning about
this estimated [__] and i could just
tell my look on their face that wasn't
their world
like there's some great comics that you
don't know about because they're not
good at social media
it's not their world
it's not they're not [__] hilarious
they're not just good at social media
these guys were good at one thing and
that was roofing they didn't want to
talk to anybody they weren't into that
[__] they didn't want to talk to nobody
so i understood why they didn't want to
go for the big picture because they got
to talk to people [__] that i wanted the
big picture had this opportunity
so there was no [__] googling back
then there was no you know i'll just
yahoo it now i had to go home and
[__]
you know go to a library and figure out
how do you become an estimator and i
checked out some [__] books and i
looked into it and then i did
when i was a kid i used to write the
coaches ncaa coaches for their college
workouts for basketball i would take you
know bob foster at the time from north
carolina i went back to that and i
started calling these [__] roofing
companies
carl
year there was four companies we dealt
with
and i talked to them and they're like
listen we all have estimating
seminars and we have information
seminars and you come out to live for
three days and learn everything about
our rubber we'll give you pamphlets
we'll get you started we'll teach you
how to be a [__] estimator so
i did all the things it was like six
weekends in a row
and then i took a [__] estimating job
in
homes and residential [__] roofing
so every day on the way home me and mike
would be driving through a neighborhood
and i go mike pull over
and i'd see somebody with a [__] up
roof and i'd put
i'd just pass out
25 [__] uh flyers
in their mailboxes you're not gonna
believe this i put on like 25 [__]
flyers
and one day and by the time i got home
there'd be like three calls when can you
come out and look at the roof saturday
7 a.m and i would go out there
i knew what i was doing but i didn't
really know what i was doing so there
was another friend of mine that worked
at black roofing his name was dg grebo
good [__] dude
he came up with my in-laws he was like
the master in residential ruse so i
called him one day and i go listen i'm
thinking of doing this and he goes if
you do it if you need any help let me
know i go let's want we go out tomorrow
i think it was the first house it wasn't
like in our vat let's go out to our
nevada
and let's look at these uh
these houses and he came out with me
dawg we sold two of them right on the
spot
like
thousand dollar bids they're like yep
absolutely we'll send it to our we'll
send to our insurance and we'll have the
check for you in 30 days all we asked
for was 50 deposit
boom we must have done this every
saturday for like [__]
two months let me tell you something we
packed our [__] schedule up
packed every weekend so i worked five
days a week on the roof
and then saturdays we get to the roof we
pick up the material at six in the
morning get to the roof
me and him would get on the [__] roof
and tear off the old roof
then we [__] put all the seething and
all that [__] and we do all the flashing
we go home at five get back there sunday
at seven a.m and we'd [__] bang out
the shingles i had my own [__] egg
gun it was tremendous
put the [__] shingles down clean up
around the area and we split [__] 12
50 every [__] weekend it was 625
dollars a day
it was fantastic it was [__]
fantastic we did this
constantly people were like you work
seven days a week
[__] yeah i did it for about two or
three months and then i was like
i don't know i gotta figure something
out in my life i enjoyed it
i enjoyed what i was doing and you ready
for this we were wrapping up the job we
won
and i started [__] ptl construction
pfl construction company in denver
i called them one day started talking to
the dudes like i'm from [__]
middlesex or something new jersey we
started talking he's like you come out
here anytime
and look at all our prints and [__]
put bids on them are you [__] kidding
me i would [__] go in the morning
drop off the material from my
brother-in-law then i would shoot out
there i got myself a little yellow
construction that they gave me
dog i would walk in that building
like i knew what i was doing i knew
nothing
i'd walk upstairs there'd be a bunch of
estimators up there
measuring [__] i'd [__] look at their
notes i'd steal [__] from them like the
numbers and i submitted them one day i
actually booked
a commercial job like a 600 000
commercial job
my brother-in-law's were burning hot
because listen
they didn't think i was gonna move on
with it but i did and on my own
i [__] was nailing this work and
having a great time when i nailed that
big job i could see that this was not
they were like pushing that leg and it
kind of hurt my feelings it kind of hurt
my feelings because finally i found
something i liked
and uh
i don't know it was like they didn't
want to do it like i was all gung-ho
about this [__] idea
here i was i took all the training
seminars i did everything i had to do
i started going to these companies i
didn't know what i was doing and finally
i booked a job that was going to be
profitable
like i came in i would have made the
company extra money because i just you
know i knew that
there was six of the seven of us in the
crew and we didn't give a [__] we worked
[__] hard so we were doing
40 squares a day if you're a roofer
you're like joey that's a lot that's
what we were doing we were savages we
didn't we did not [__] stop we took
our job with pride i got mike to work
with me and i got this other hippie dude
to work with me that i knew i used to
buy weed from his girlfriend nice jewish
chick he was jewish
his work ethic was okay he was a hip he
had no strength
you know he was like a vegan and [__] he
smelled funny but he was a good dude and
we had him out there every day with us
like years later when i got separated he
went against me and god knows what
happened to him but for a lot of people
don't know
there was some problems at home like
there were some problems at home i had
you know i was working i was working
seven [__] days a week that was the
problem you know i'm saying plus i was
getting a highlight two nights but not
all-nighters i would just do a couple of
[__] bumps drink a beer and do bang
one out i had like a little outdoor
patio
uh that i would go out to at night it
was really wasn't really it was a sun
room that's what it was i would go out
there at night and make believe i was
looking at the mountains
with a telescope or whatever the [__]
but uh
december that year like i was doing
great with them and [__]
and then it was uh
in in colorado at that time you know now
things have changed you know it's
snowing in [__] texas
you know when i was a kid it never
snowed in texas but it's snowing in
[__] texas now one time i was going
to texas arcana on a [__] greyhound
bus i was gonna work somewhere and i'm i
woke up in the middle of night and i saw
snow and the guys i went up there i'm
like are we in texas like yeah [__] i
never see snow down here but things are
changing so and now they've had snow for
like three days freezing weather really
doesn't matter joy why are you talking
about texas in the snow
anyway
um
you know it was really cold
and i was talking to mike roebuck like
after i said the story on patreon i call
my friend mike roebuck
who lives in uh grand junction and we
were talking i go you know i was
thinking about when i used to pick you
up in the morning we used to go roof we
were [__] laughing our asses all
telling little stupid stories
but uh
we did this job me mike and my
brother-in-law that was like a skeleton
crew
it was like the day before christmas we
had to shovel the roof
and load materials on there this was the
last section we were doing that it was
just like a week
a week's uh
worth of work
and it was gonna be because the jersey
crew had gone home so it was just gonna
be me
the prowler mike and the jewish kid and
maybe jim the old man
and we had to go up there and it was
guys it was brutal like i had been
outside before i had skied and [__]
but we had a [__] hilo up on the roof
they had to carry it up like they had to
bring it up the day before when we got
there there was a foot of snow we had to
clean off the [__] thing i mean it
was just a nightmare and we had to bring
materials up there and i'll never forget
that my brother goes dog
it's going to be like this for the next
two weeks we're just taking the time off
like all right fine
he goes i'll pay you whatever i don't
care you guys my brother-in-laws are
paying me a great salary
by the way
from the beginning there was no trainee
pay there was nothing they're like
listen we're just gonna pay you like a
[__] journeyman not a lot of people
do that and that's why i gave them i
gave my heart and soul to them for a lot
of different reasons but when they
[__] lifted the rock i'm all in when
you lift the rock i'm all in
so uh
well that two week break my my wife
would take at the time my wife would
take
my daughter to day care she would cut
hair
and basically i would like pick her up
at daycare when it snowed and
i would just sit around all day take a
ride maybe smoke some dope i didn't
smoke dope like i did you know five
years ago but i was smoking dope and i
uh watched i went i had that video store
in boulder had three floors all the best
movies
so i said [__] it you know if i don't
have any work i'll catch up on some
[__] movies i'm a big movie buff
and i rented a movie called punchline
and it had uh
tom hanks and the flying nun in it
and it was about a comedy club in jersey
like in newark somewhere and had angel
salazar damon wayans a bunch of [__]
good comics on there
i knew tom hanks was but i didn't know
the rest of the guy was i know angel
salazar from scarface
but i didn't know anybody else you know
but i really enjoyed the movie it was a
funny movie about a comedy a comic tom
hanks and he's selling material and he
does
you know it didn't really matter you
know what it opened up my mind
to comedy i go wow all those guys told
me
i could be a comedian and this is what
it is they all had lockers at the comedy
club and
they went down every night performed
their act
there was like a camaraderie you know
i'm like
maybe i'll [__] try comedy you know
then the holidays came and went
january was upon us and i was back to
work there was no [__] comedy
but
like maybe
three weeks later
this is how what fate feels it works
it's [__] weird i got there
and usually we'd all take a break
um we would call in the order at the
breakfast place
and one of them one of us would go pick
it up and bring the food back and we'd
eat right outside if if it was too cold
we ain't not trucks or we'd go
to the [__] uh diner and just you
know eat there we'd call it in and go so
we just sit for like 20 minutes it
wouldn't [__] up our labor
so uh
i was this [__] roofer i was already
getting calls to
you know for the for the spring of 91 i
was already getting calls and [__]
i'm like this is wild i'm gonna have my
own little roof roofing
company on the side me and this dang guy
and we just do work on the weekends how
long will it last
i mean when am i gonna get a chance to
see my family like i said at that time i
wasn't a big family man i was still
living on the
thing that uh
i was still living under the premise
that a man just went out and made money
you know we did what we did we came home
and we did the best we could we we shook
the baby and then you know go take the
baby go give it a bet
i gotta watch the news on my favorite
game show or whatever the [__]
i didn't look at it for what it was you
know so
i uh
i went to work one day and they were
like joey do you mind going to pick up
the breakfast with behind
i was like [__] yeah i go over there i
went in there and i never forgot i sat
down
at this diner [__] whole place small
really great breakfast is some really
good green chili
i never forget i walked in
and i [__] uh
you know ordered the breakfast and the
waitress she goes i'll get it all boxed
up for you
i go let me get a bowl of green chili
while i wait you know me i'm a [__]
gavon
and
while i was waiting for the chili i
looked around
i was sitting at the counter you know
and
it was 10 30 so the breakfast rush had
left and people always leave behind the
newspaper
so i stepped back just to see where the
[__] newspaper was and it was a rocky
mountain news i'll never forget this
guy's my
when i stuck my hand in the paper
i stuck the thumb in the middle
and when i pulled it out
the news when i pulled it towards me the
newspaper opened
and as fate
be my [__] god is my witness it
opened up to a page
with a picture of this comedian andy
payden from denver up on stage bent over
like talking to the audience
and on the left side on the far right
side it was a picture of rosen and bar
not on the same stage like they had you
know graphic that in there some way or
another cgi
like [__] tommy lee's dick in that
[__] movie that
did you see that yeah i couldn't deal
with that either we'll discuss that in a
minute
but uh i was blown away with that
no comment
and i opened it up and there's andy
peyton roseanne bar in the middle of the
page it had do you want to be a stand-up
comic
and i felt like that [__] you would
feel the goosebumps on your [__] neck
just go
and i was like what the [__] is this and
i never forget do you want to be a
stand-up comic and they were talking
about roseanne's fame and how she busted
out of denver
and the clubs she worked at in denver i
didn't even know there were these clubs
like i said there was no internet
in [__] nine january of ninety one
you know i i i didn't have it
so i'm looking at all this [__] and
they're talking about open mics
they're talking about the three clubs in
denver and there's a club about to open
they just said all this [__] on there
and i was like like all the information
i needed like when i got off when i
watched
the punchline movie i remember i went in
the kitchen and i called you know 4-1-1
i go comedy clubs in the area and they
must have told me just the comedy works
you know and i remember calling them
going do you have a new talent night
yeah we have tuesday nights you get
three minutes
call the week before and we'll call you
the week of and i'm like okay i'll call
you back [__] you i'm not ever calling
back i'm too scared to get on stage
but i remember reading that article it
was [__] just
you know like when you have a question
this answered everything in one [__]
swoop
like just everything like open mics
where they were what time they started
who ran them you know really interesting
[__] article i think i just
stole the newspaper but on the bottom
it had like comedy programs you know
that like uh
improv olympic los angeles and that like
whatever some other thing in los angeles
you know i'm in denver i'm in [__]
boulder what are you talking about but
the last one it was like comedy class
taught by jeff harms
at the university of colorado
starts like
february whatever till february whatever
it's three
weeks in a row
so we're talking about
[__] uh you know
21 years ago 31 years ago this was 32
years ago that's crazy the class was 33
dollars
like if you join a class in new york to
do stand-up comedy at a club with a
stand-up like me it would cost you like
you know it would cost you your first
son
it would cost like four [__] hundred
and fifty dollars and you gotta pay a
250 deposit and give him fifty dollars a
week for the rest of the [__] classes
and you're like i don't even have that
[__] i can't even pay rent you know when
you want to get into stand-up like i
said you never drive to an open mic in a
lamborghini nobody drives to an open
[__] like a lamborghini so
i mean i was poor as [__] so when they
said the university of colorado for 33
bucks
three sundays
from one to four in the afternoon
are you [__] kidding me or what
i don't know what day of the week it was
i remember going home that night
[__] going right to the university of
colorado the student center and just
paying the 33 dollars in cash and being
so [__] happy when i walked in that
was like other because i was signing up
for other class i'm like oh there's
still spots left because when you get to
those things you're like yo this is
stand-up comic style and they're like
yeah we have spots left how many spots
left i mean and they're like nah we got
plenty of spots i'm like thank god maybe
it'll just be me
but no i was uh it was it was like 20
other guys and uh
you know guys you never know
where you're gonna end up but again
it goes back to nothing happens on the
couch
nothing happens in your house watching
the tv
you know mike and i were talking a
couple weeks ago mike's like this
this wedding band wants me to help i go
go
nobody wants to be in a [__] wedding
man but
you don't know who you're going to bump
into
and right now in today's world you might
walk in you know for years when i was
young
they would say if you wanted to become
like a [__] movie star just get a job
bartending
and that somebody would discover yeah
the only thing you discovered is how you
suck dick that's the only discovery
you're gonna [__] make
you know nobody gets it but
because bruce willis did it
bruce willis was a bartender michael
mann came in got him miami vice he
auditioned he got something else so
people always say well i can bartend
well
you know we're living in a society now
where
you might walk in as a sound guy for a
band
into a venue
you talk to some creepy looking dude and
after the show you find that that creepy
looking dude owns the [__] venue
and he's like how many days a week do
you work with these guys you're like
maybe one a week
he's like right now i'm looking for a
full-time guy man
you know you could run the whole lot and
there you were going [__]
i'm not even get might get paid by this
wedding band
but this dude's offering me a full-time
gig this would have never happened if i
was home
so yeah the wedding band's paying you
the small 25 but you wipe your ass with
it's basically gas and a couple pretzels
from wawa and then [__]
this guy so that's what it's all about
it's it's who the [__] would have
thought
that this story was going to take you
from
roofing to [__] comedy that's
an unbelievable story like i mean
the other day when i was kind of going
into it on patreon i'm like i'm so sad
that this only has 20 minutes because
there's so much to this [__] story
that it woke me up
like remembering this story made my
[__] week you know i hope it makes
you a week i don't know just to let you
know anything is [__] possible
anything it's monday man anything is
possible when you wake up on a monday
you wake up and you go what the [__]
i'm doing it all over again no no no
you got another chance all over again to
tap into your [__] adventure it could
happen this monday it could happen
wednesday it could happen friday you're
not gonna know but monday when i get up
mondays i i can't tell you how excited i
am on monday mornings even though i wake
up to nothing
i might wake up to maybe the [__] i
gotta answer emails and i go to jiu
jitsu and i got something like a two
o'clock draftkings or something
doesn't matter to me something might
happen i might get better at something
you know i wasn't good at something last
week maybe this week i'll be a little
better on it maybe last week i couldn't
walk 35 minutes on the treadmill this
week i can maybe this is the week
something makes me go [__]
go get a [__] uh playa bowl and while
i'm walking out i see a goddamn lottery
ticket oh they're up to 400 million huh
you walk in there put a dollar and walk
out and next thing you're getting a call
from lottery people we got to check for
400 million you're like
yeah i went to get fruit look at that
nothing but it starts by trying it's a
whole new [__] year man and whatever
happened last year
it happened last year this year is
[__] for the taking
you know she wouldn't give you a piece
ass last year good
you got a whole new year to try again
and bust it you know what i'm saying if
that job didn't hire you last year good
you got a whole new year to torture them
all over again
start calling them again well i looked
at your application well look again
look again
i'm the guy listen you got the guy for
the [__] job on the phone why are we
even having this conversation
right now everybody's looking for a
[__] job so if you want to step one
up a notch in your life
now is the time
now is the time i'm [__] you know how
ashamed i am that i got felonies and
you're not gonna [__] sponge him now
for years everybody was telling me oh
you could have sponged your felonies
joey it's easy [__] you i just called
two attorneys they're like oh
we don't know you got a call you got to
find the original d.a my d.a in 1987 is
he's [__] punishing environmental
people now for the feds i don't even
know if he's doing that he might be
selling girl scout cookies at this
[__] point without the bails and [__]
like that so listen my point is it's
[__] monday we made it another
week i'm fired the [__] up i'm feeling
good i'm doing everything i'm supposed
to be doing
whatever things ain't happening like i
wanted to who gives a [__] we're alive
we're smoking weed i'm loving you
[__] i'm loving what i'm doing
and that's what this is all about we
forgot what this is all about we got
caught up in all the [__] people
getting desensitized i'm taking my mu
who gives a [__] i don't give a [__]
what you do i don't give a [__] we're
not doing nothing wrong over here but if
that's what you want to do who gives a
frenchman's [__] for two years i looked
at that [__] people making little
[__] comments some [__] jerkoffs
making me fair i don't even give a [__]
you know why
because we're still standing like elton
john and eddie [__] won i think it
was 81 that's one of my favorite elton
john songs i'm still standing that's all
that matters so for all these people
that keep talking and their opinions and
get them off and shut them up and cancel
culture listen every day i give thanks
because i'm still [__] standing and
that's the uncle joey's joint
for february 7th this beautiful [__]
monday mike said he fixed the lights i
don't look like bella lugosi anymore and
this [__] i looked at myself i
looked like i had all plastic surgery
you know these [__] with the
stretch faces and [__] but uncle joey's
back kooky chew my i just found it you
ever lose a vapor pen like listen i
always lose my weed stuff for like two
weeks and i don't sweat it
like you lose like your wallet you start
sweating
that's fine i know it's in the heat in
the car i know it's either the desk it's
in a jacket
but i lost this like two weeks ago i
didn't even tell nobody usually accuse
somebody somebody stole my paper bed
nobody stole it it's weed related i got
high put in this pocket and i took the
[__] jacket off and i'm like i guess
i lost the thing
[Music]
yeah i think this is out of juice i got
to put a new filter in here or something
this was a good filter while it lasted
[__] looks like the battery's dead
yeah you think so
this one's charged
yeah let me hit it up that yeah i like
these little dude listen i'm not going
to tell you this is going to blow your
world you're going to see purple lions
and [__] like that
just put it on here i think you just hit
that one
no i don't want to give you covert again
[__]
breathe in the air
[Music]
um
yeah that's a hard hitting [__] vapor
pen
on a monday morning with uncle joey if
you ain't smoking go [__] yourself
we're back
i'm not quitting till i got the ipas
like i used to tell lee if you stop by
the [__] uh
ice cream shop don't forget ask for the
rainbow ruts and the white truffle
i got like a little rainbow ruts no
white truffle i gotta give ice cream
shop a congo is my [__] white truffle
let me tell you something listen the new
coco batch is strong which mike had some
the new rainbow rush is strong at 36
and that [__] white truffle i
smoked that like two months ago and my
eyebrows jumped out of my [__] head
[Music]
i'm loving this
i'm loving that we're having a good time
on the [__] joint i'm loving that i'm
smoking dope again i'm loving that i'm
healthy and i'm loving that you
[__] are still here having a
great time don't forget
it's super bowl week you gotta lay into
these [__] call them right now
whoever's inviting you over if i see
hummus i'm shooting a [__] you
understand me it's a great game you got
[__] uh
cincinnati playing the rams my old alma
mater out there in california it's gonna
be a hell of a week out there they beat
somebody up already last week there's
gonna be a lot of [__] muggings they
were charging
a hundred bucks to park
two weeks ago in l.a for the [__]
for the [__] playoff game jesus
christ people are thieves when people
are down
this week i saw some guy was charging 4
200 bucks for a parking spot a mile from
the stadium
so if you're going to the super bowl you
better [__] vaseline that a-hole
because they're taking your ass like
those burglars took charles bronson's
wife's [__] and death wish one and
two you know what i'm saying they're
gonna [__] you [__] up so
don't be walking mind your business if
you're going to la this week cancel now
watch the game at home
why are you going to put yourself
through that they even rob some they
even had an armed robbery
at the [__] uh
four seasons
so you know i listen if you're going out
there god bless you
i wouldn't [__] advise it what's the
game on your couch i'm sure there's
plenty of parties
in your area i even got like two two
people invited me to a little small
[__] get-together for whatever i'm
gonna go bring a little vapor pen
look at uncle joey i look like john
lennon the cover of [__] imagine
i love you [__] have a great
day
stay black and we'll be back wednesday
morning tip top magoo on the ninth right
today's the seventh wednesday's the
night all right i love you [__]
stay black and here's a word for my
[__] sponsors
all right i want to thank you guys
for being here on a monday morning
getting me fired up hopefully i got you
[__] fired up but listen the joint is
brought to you by
muchu
valentine's day is seven days away and
you're sitting there scratching your
head you know what you want
your big fat arrow in a heart-shaped box
[Music]
let bluetooth be your personal cupid
listen bluetooth tremendous
it's easy to get it tastes good it goes
down easy
and you'll be slinging dick within a
half hour you can take it any time day
and night and listen the process is
simple sign up at bluetooth.com and talk
to one of the licensed medical providers
once you're approved he received
prescription within days the best part
it's all online who are you kidding no
doctor's office no pharmacy no judgment
it ships right to your door and a
discreet package nobody knows dick
get it way cheaper than a pharmacy so if
you could benefit from extra confidence
when it's time to get down get down
blue chew can help you know what i'm
saying and he got a special deal for
joint listeners
try blue chew free
when you use promo code joey at checkout
just pay five dollars for shipping
that's how i'm opening up on a monday
that's bluetooth.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month for free
visit bluetooth.com
for more details and important safety
information i want to thank blue for you
for sponsoring
the joint
okay i also want to thank onyx
tremendous they always put this podcast
together they've been putting this
podcast together since jesus left
chicago supplements that's what i can
help you with you want kettlebells talk
to joe rogan i can just do the
supplements
and some of like the beef jerkys and
stuff like that tremendous but guess
what black label alpha brain is back in
stock
back to the back back where it belongs
so godaddy.com right now
read learn see what they got their
supplements are second to none whether
it's the protein powder the shrimp deck
the shrimp tech immunosport or
the staple alpha brain right now
get something put in code church
joey or joint and get 10 off your order
delivered right to your crib
it's that easy on it is the best and
from the heart of new jersey the joint
is brought to you by draftkings listen
let's cut the [__]
we've been [__] around all season i
understand maybe you don't like to bet
maybe your father was the an abusive
gambler i don't [__] know but one
thing i got to tell you you got an
opportunity to make great money this
weekend
with draftkings the official sports
betting partner of super bowl 56 we got
a super deal for new customers i know
you haven't been gambling all year but
i'm giving you a shot at 56-1 odds on
either team just bet 5 hours
and get 280 in free bets if you get
what do you get you get 560. see my math
is always money now if if footballing is
stuff i understand but you got a
tremendous ufc card on saturday
live from houston texas throw down and
who win the fight
and how they'll finish and so much more
fists are going to fly in the main event
middleweight tattlebot so don't miss out
download the draftking sportsbook app
now
and use promo code joey j-o-e-y just bet
five hours on either super bowl 5016.
and get 280 and free bets
that's promo code joey at draftking
sportsbook you got to be 21 or older
minimum age requirement 21 and location
varied by jurisdiction
see draftkings.com sportsbook for full
list of requirements and state-specific
responsible gaming resources now void
we're prohibited now if you've got a
gammon problem call 1-800 gambler if
you're in tennessee 1-800-889-9789
in connecticut
[Music]
eight seven 888-789-7777 eight hope
and there you have it my people
draftkings.com
i wanna thank draftkings i wanna thank
on it
and i wanna thank
my beautiful people
at uh blue chew here we go
[Music]
i love you [__] see you wednesday
tip top magoo
[Music]
so
you